un nuevo capítulo en la investigación
del asesinato del presidente john en el
moisés el primer ministro ariel angie
destituyó un fiscal después de que éste
solicitara investigarlo en relación al
crimen y prohibir su salida del país una
acusación que el primer ministro
considera como una falta administrativa
grave y una estrategia de distracción
las acciones para crear confusión e
impedir el ejercicio de la justicia no
deben darse en contra de neiva los
verdaderos culpables los autores
intelectuales los responsables del
asesinato del presidente lleven el moy
serán llevados ante la justicia y
castigados por sus actos y el hadji con
hachís y pitbull efe y es que en la
madrugada del 7 de julio horas después
de los hechos el jefe de gobierno habló
dos veces por teléfono con uno de los
principales sospechosos del magnicidio y
fue nombrado primer ministro dos días
antes del crimen cuando un comando
entrenado militarmente entró en la
residencia privada del mandatario y lo
mató a balazos un hecho que conmocionó a
la nación más pobre del continente
americano que enfrenta crecientes
problemas de seguridad y de pandillas
por el momento al menos 44 personas se
encuentran en prisión preventiva entre
ellos 18 colombianos que formaban parte
del comando que asesinó al mandatario
junto a dos de miembros del cuerpo de
seguridad de moix acusados por no oponer
resistencia